You get obsessed with things sometimes.
I mean very obsessed...
...and you really get into it.
Right.
And then you just sort of drop it one day and you move on...
...and you get obsessed with something else.
What is your latest obsession?
What's the thing you're obsessed with these days?
K-Pop.
K-Pop?
It's Korean pop music.
Yeah.
And it's beyond excellent.
It's the best thing you've ever seen.
What is it about?
Is it the videos?
Is it the music?
Is it the whole thing combined?
It's all so addictive.
Yeah.
Very addictive.
Do you have a current favorite?
When we did the Spiderman premiere in Seoul, Korea,...
...we were onstage with a band called 2ne1.
Do you see?
Wow!